[Music]
in VidCon Germany are you got very
submitted by love you baby beer oh yeah
like a mile we love you too it's like a
KUB KUB blonde coke 100 kumquat little
kumquat kumquat con a self-proclaimed
hmm thank you miss what is the water on
famous Instagram models caught on camera
hurling insults at the security guards
during the car love besides you guys see
this oh this isn't so bad
watch this [ __ ] what Beth [ __ ] oh my god
okay I want to see some snobbery dude
you don't want to [ __ ] beat this kid
yeah almost you all right so there's
this Instagram [ __ ] miss [ __ ] model
yeah that's I think Christian burned
it's a boy yeah and then doesn't even
have any fun but he's a certified [ __ ]
though cool sounds like it this one the
behavior alone show me this [ __ ]
video so I could [ __ ] roast this
little [ __ ]
can you please roast him like he's a
piece of chicken yeah so 19 years old
from Canada he had $27,000 Oh give me
shut up we're gonna get a shout-out on
your Instagram please cute - and then I
can't even imagine having that much
27,000 that's a lot though why is he
demanding so much respect and his famous
famous he's a Manos incident model do
Eva Jess got more followers she just got
followers because of money
don't accounts out there to have more
[ __ ] followers dudes hell yeah anybody
out there that does have that and you're
not a piece of [ __ ] you're doing a great
job
pretty awesome excellent yeah it's
actually quite a feat well you're not
famous you look like a Walmart Justin
Bieber
rule I love those schmuck a nice tips
yeah always 90 times listen what I'm
going to show you guys the video so
actually in the video I'm going to show
you first I'll show you the one that
went viral where is he she's like
berating two security guards and then
right after that video clip you're going
to see another video clip of him doing
the same thing to a different security
guard on a different day Wow Wow he's
like the security guard hater who is
recording it all right people when I was
near my awesome here we go I have a lot
more money than you listen to me a lot
of money
whoa that's not nice I thought Canadians
were supposed to be nice you're handy we
visit laughing at it that's funny
come on what is rare he's wearing is
uniform you [ __ ] idiot
he's doing it for fashion I want to get
off the [ __ ] out he's touching them ugly
you just threatened me from head out
you're irrelevant and ugly what's the
fuss on your now that's so [ __ ] up
dude Oh Edgar Tafel these guys are just
doing their job you [ __ ]
that's how you're so calm so
professional why you basically look at
you
we're not but it means our uniform you
mean like what are you [ __ ] wearing
oh really I'll do it I know you haven't
told much yeah you can knock out the
security guard yeah seriously you really
that's human you're so rich and famous
and known why weren't you invited to
VidCon and why don't you if you were so
rich and famous why aren't you in the
[ __ ] VIP oh what's so funny he's like
you're irrelevant you're not important
but you're not even allowed in there so
I guess you're pretty irrelevant - you
don't even have a community PAC yeah if
he's so rich and famous what are the
pocket of industry path I think when
that first came out he only had like
maybe 16 thousand maybe I'm not sure
I'll follow it
nah I don't know no maybe 26 oh then I
know that the some people of internet
made an Instagram account from the
security guard just to piss that [ __ ]
off and you got way more followers of
his yeah it has like his Instagram is
like half 40 or 50 last time oh oh oh
twenty fifty thousand and now he's more
famous than him vest oh oh you're just
you're just doing their job yeah I
wonder why people who look like my guy
to somebody's face like I'm going to
beat your ass and they don't throw a fit
yeah once you say like in public to
somebody i'ma beat your ass you have to
follow through with it I answer that in
videos like you're just saying it for
entertainment purposes or you're kind of
like trying to be funny but in a
face-to-face confrontation if you say
the words i'ma beat your ass you usually
have to follow through with it or that's
what I thought
I don't anymore I am mentioning those
words and not doing it makes them look
worse yeah in my opinion that's like I'm
gonna stab you right now there's no
stabbing that happened I know absolutely
not you're a [ __ ]
you're a fake sack of [ __ ] yeah so this
is Christian old Instagram account where
he had 2009 oh my god and so as a now he
he did that technique where you follow a
lot of people and then they follow you
back so you have 7,000
following so what he says is that
apparently he done a third-party app to
unfollow people because he says he
wanted his page to look more
professional and so by doing that it was
violating instagrams
rules and so instagrams deleted his cage
so that's how he is claiming how his
cage
deleting imported the [ __ ] out of him
yeah so he created a new one now it's
private and so this is a famous and so
now a 100 K more famous this entire page
is really sweet I can a lot of selfies
with other youtubers and you know I
approach that is actual page it has 484
posts so that I think that's it actually
oh yeah this is his actual piece also no
one didn't make it know that I'm very
informed yeah so he was just posting a
lot of images of other youtubers
approaching them like one of them gave
them a gift card and just said sorry
like apologizing for Christian behavior
like really famous people community like
the real famous people they're the cool
ones right yeah everyone came together
for it for him the people that are
actually relevant yeah why would you out
I didn't think that that that was like
reality like I see it in movies or
whatever I didn't think people actually
said I'm famous you're not I make more
money than you like that's going to
change anything did he think that the
gates would open oh really you do okay
well please I know let me risk my job as
a security guard so you you're the
famous person that could come in even
26,000 I know but like people like that
dog he'll eventually get in age so it's
all good I really want to see what his
parents are like because that's where it
stems from yeah so apparently uh so he
was interviewed and McDonald Alert and
so they interviewed him and the security
guard consider in that interview a
Christian was just saying how he was in
a bad place no black hero and he's just
[ __ ] stupid yeah he was drunk at the
time and you're just Starbucks you know
he shouldn't even mentioned that he was
drunk because alcohol shows your true
personality he's 19 like yeah the real
famous people never act like this
because we get this sometimes too at our
gym it'll be like the people that are
just budding like fitness IG oh you know
who I am and just showing my front staff
like how many followers I got 800
followers how good followers or whatever
and then the people that actually are
someone when they come in they just pay
no one knows they just come in they just
train whatever and then later don't like
DME looking for I stopped by her gym was
awesome I'm all should you let me know I
would have got you in for free but like
people that are actually big they have
class
you know they don't need to like try to
floss we've all got a million followers
or whatever
I heard though this [ __ ] is acting
like that because his buddies printed
out some fake passes and they got caught
with them and they couldn't get in so
then they were just doing whatever they
could reason for the second video
because then when when he was being
interviewed he asked them to like so
this isn't just the first time he did it
like there's footage of you doing it to
another security arty he's like well
that was because yeah my friends printed
out fake passes and we're going to kick
down I was just angry and drunk and I
was you were drunk two days in a row
that's because you were a [ __ ] loser
that don't have real passes so we get
underneath on you know the funny thing
is yes stupid
I heard that no one was really checking
for passes there so how the [ __ ] did he
get caught I don't people were just
walking in and out so so [ __ ] dumb
he's like listen dude I'm just doing a
lot of cocaine and I was just like what
the [ __ ] bro my stop incriminated
yourself like I'm talking such as some
kids and they wouldn't let me in during
that same interview team he was saying
that he was reading comments and that in
some of the comments there was someone
that said yeah I went to high school
with that guy who he always grew up
being like a rich prick and he would
always constantly try to act like he was
better than everyone else and because
team ended up asking him like wait so
did you grow up with privileges like
with money and stuff and he was like no
no nothing like that and okay well I
mean yeah I guess my family does kind of
make money but no but it wasn't like
that in my kid just listening to this it
was really hard cuz he couldn't even
explain until that that's the thing too
it's like man I'm not a parent or
anything else like that but you know you
can't it's hard for me when I see a kid
like that because that's also like the
parents fault too because I know in
Riverside like that a couple friends who
are very affluent but I never knew they
had a lot of money because they never
flaunted it like that yeah you know like
they did a good great job if they don't
come off in title exactly I would have
never known like they came from money
because my my mind of people who come
from money are entitled people like him
but that's not the case you know it's
just all about how you raise a kid you
know if you raise your kid to be like
that and you still think that it's okay
all you got to do is put a bullet in
slag in this pretty sense what a lot of
people don't do is
him going on image you gotta let me in
the real famous people are inside trying
to go home yep how long am I getting
[ __ ] here for a [ __ ] brought me in
through the fact it was a VIP tunnels
and now I'm trying to [ __ ] go home
like if you're really famous you
wouldn't be outside try to break in the
entire thing wasn't the factly he was
trying to get in the first video was
because there was this man I was getting
tackled by the security team like
everyone was going all over this oh okay
like bury the Hanalei in a chokehold and
she lesson Christians started going off
on a security guard saying like why are
you guys treating him like an animal
like he can't betray like an animal so
then he starts treating them like edible
dog cause he obscure saying like they
were treating him like a dog like you
can't treat humans like that and then
you're like like you're [ __ ] ugly and
irrelevant okay we know and then he
wants a ready-to-go wait wait wait like
good job and then he was like I just
care about people that's what my dog how
much only bad people how much one about
that that wasn't even the security guard
that was tilter - it was it not it
wasn't you just [ __ ] talking [ __ ] to
another security guard has nothing to do
with it because he's emotionally
affected like a little [ __ ] exactly you
know what he is though he's like this
plane just jumping in so he could get a
little bit of the thing yeah it's just
like the direct fiery Antony may look at
you or everyone talking about you you
don't want things with that though you
[ __ ] idiot I know he reminds me of
that what do you what do people call
them like neo liberals or something like
that were they like everything is like
offensive to that also it's actually oh
yeah so like they they witness on being
tackled and now they have to voice their
opinion and start talking down to a
security because they're guilty by
association and apparently I guess being
blue collar is now insult
I never boot I never thought that that
would ever be an info I mean if you say
there's nobody valid I think you should
have sworn that kind that was four times
your size just to see what what happened
yeah I mean that guy living tired Kevin
Sorbo yeah it's funny good like the the
guy that he was setting you in a huge
guys he was just laughing like I could
knock your [ __ ] ass now let's go
outside yeah
cute he's one of those people the
Instagram models are the dudes who are
they have six-pack ABS because they're
like 92 pounds it would have been tight
once the kitty guards like been to jail
he's grabbed by the
that like if you're in jail or buff
[ __ ] what huh and you would have been
like mmm I want to be outside though I
wish someone did something because I
want to see these expressions completed
you know cuz guys are hard they always
think oh we're going to throw it down
we're going to fight with the fool that
are really hard to like I don't give a
[ __ ] about fighting yeah I'm a buff like
your ass what are all my positive people
I want to hear your thoughts put it in
the comments below because if you're
negative shut the hell up and go drink
some raid please but if you're very pond
to leave it in comments below for the
last video over here